and i'm guessing he like you he's going
to put the rook king on the seventh row
make the move few seconds oh there he
comes there we go and magnus retreating
the knight this is very strong move it
looks like attacking the black bishop
but the black bishop cannot move because
it has to defend its rook and there's
tension here black counter attack
against white's bishop white's bishop
moved there's a standoff the black
bishop is up for grabs white's knight
wants to take it but there's also a pin
on the d line so if white's knight moves
and takes that black bishop right now
oh wow magnus nice with a killer blow i
think he's just given a check
distracting the black bishop and he's
about to win the black rook mamidorov
resigns it's over and we see a smile on
magnus carlson's face after making a
comeback playing a great game here with
the white pieces that means these two
are now tied after two games in their
match magnus carlsen running off but we
definitely saw that smile was this one
of those games that he just loves
playing david